yeah it is a short report it's about 12
uh pages long uh and it just sets out at
the beginning uh the various things that
uh uh processors that sue grey was asked
it talks about how an investigation was
launched on the 8th of december
into what happened in whitehall during
the pandemic and in the department for
education how su gray took over on the
17th of december and how she was given a
terms of reference to look at a whole
series of different events inside number
10. uh we're going to go straight to
page seven uh which looks at her general
findings so looking at these for the
first time together against the backdrop
of the pandemic when the government was
asking citizens to accept far-reaching
restrictions on their lives some of the
behavior surrounding these gatherings is
difficult to justify at least some of
the gatherings in question represent a
serious failure to observe not just the
high standards expected of those working
at the heart of government but also of
the standards expected of the entire
british population at the time at times
it seems there was too little thought
given to what was happening across the
country in considering the
appropriateness of some of these
gatherings the risks that they presented
to public health and how they might
appear to the public there were failures
of leadership and judgment by different
parts of number 10 and the cabinet
office at different times some of the
events should not have been allowed to
take place other events should not have
been allowed to develop as they did
the excessive consumption of alcohol is
not appropriate in a professional
workplace at any time steps must be
taken to ensure that every government
department has a clear and robust policy
in place covering the consumption of
alcohol in the workplace now she goes on
to talk about specific and more general
findings related to certain events the
use of the garden at number 10 downing
street should be primarily for the prime
minister and the private residents of
number 10 and number 11 downing street
during the pandemic it was often used as
an extension of the workplace as it was
a covert secure means of holding group
meetings in a ventilated space this was
a sensible measure that staff
appreciated but the garden was also used
for gatherings without clear
authorization or oversight this was not
appropriate any official access to the
space including for meetings should be
by invitation only and in a controlled
environment some staff wanted to raise
concerns about behaviors they witnessed
at work but at times felt unable to do
so no member of staff should feel unable
to report or challenge poor conduct when
they witness it there should be easier
ways
for staff to raise such concerns
individually uh informally outside of
the line management chain the number of
staff working in number 10 downing
street has steadily increased in recent
years and in terms of size scale and
range of responsibilities it's now more
akin to a government department
and she talks about structure but then
we go on to the conclusions
the gatherings within the scope of this
investigation are spread over a 20-month
period a period that has been unique in
recent times in terms of the complexity
and breadth of the demands on public
service servants and indeed the general
public the whole of the country raised
the challenge ministers special advisers
and the civil service of which i am
proud to be a part were a key and
dedicated part of that national effort
however as i have noted a number of
these gatherings should not have been
allowed to take place or to develop in
the way that they did there is
significant learning to be drawn from
these events which must be addressed
immediately across government this does
not need to wait for the police
investigation to be concluded
so there you have the key bits of the
sugree report i just want to go back to
one absolutely critical uh paragraph
where she talks about failures of
leadership and judgment by different
bits of number 10 and the cabinet office
i think that is going to be quite a
challenge for the prime minister today